оглянитесь вокруг озерніться навколо
просто погляньте світ прекрасний Життя
теж прекрасне а навіть тоже прекрасна на
цих кадрах з 2021 року Владислав Єщенко
і його активний відпочинок подорожі та
побачення з дівчиною після лютого 2022
вже в лавах ЗСУ він фільмує дні своєї
служби на фронті чоловік Відмінно
стріляв
ці моменти тепер Він тримає лише у своїй
пам'яті
Владислав приходить на інтерв’ю з ДВ під
руку коханої обережно нащупує стілець
сідає і починає свою історію з того що
змінила його життя назавжди
30 осколків 30 уланків у мені розірване
обличчя зламана щелепа роздроблені
кістки випалені видалення очі обпалені
руки
Владислав отримав травму на фронті
будучи сапером про ризики у цій роботі
чоловік знав ще до того як пішов воювати
добровольцем у березні 2022 до
повномасштабного наступу Росії він
працював у групі гуманітарних демінерів
галотраст як волонтер робота суглоба
робота суто за правилами безпеки без
будь-якого поспіху максимально безпечно
максимальна безопасно на войне на війні
час мабуть важливіший за безпекою тому
що втрачений час може при до непоправних
наслідків
последствиям если работа на открытыми
робота на відкритій місцевості вас
можуть змалювати і все час в цю локацію
де ви автоматично починає прилітати на
спецвила з трьох їдемо я як повернуся
відразу відпишуся Бережіть себе там
після цих
слів поблизу бахмута того дня рідні та
дівчина так і не отримали від нього
повідомлення що завдання минуло успішно
внаслідок відриву одного боєприпасу
здетонували усі ті які були ізольовані я
лише відчув подив від того що вибух
темрява з він у вухах я розумію біда
єдина фраза яку я вимовив Мені потрібна
допомога все Я відчув як підбігли
підхопили мене за руки друга фраза яку я
сказав мені дуже холодно я відключився
все більше не було нічого більше не було
нічого 10 днів коми у Дніпровській
лікарні потім ще два тижні мовчання від
усіх лікарів навколо про те що сталося і
чому Владислав нічого не бачить відколи
отямився дізнатися правду боєць
наважився сам
в какой-то момент когда якийсь момент
коли я поставив запитання мене почали
прив'язувати Ну мені намагалися
зав'язати руки мабуть хотіли сказати але
я тоді зробив відмашку-рукою сказав не
треба я все розумію лікарі пішли так
нічого і не сказавши мене почали
виводити на прогулянку я підійшов
точніше я з батьком йшов прогулювався
перший кроки свої робив І ми тоді
наодинці були Я кажу тато Ми домовлялися
ніколи в житті не брехати одного щоб не
сталося давай чесно що з очима секунд на
пауза і він каже У тебе їх нема тобі їх
видалили
вердект лікарів жодного шансу на зір
численні контузії і падіння слуху до
десяти відсотків Владислав почав
реабілітацію і знайомство з життям у
суцільній темряві коштом благодійників
які відгукнулися на прохання допомогти
йому вдалося сплатити встановлення
імплантів у очі а також слуховий апарат
навчився сам готувати і користуватися
смартфоном а сьогодні за руку з коханою
валерією впевнено йде вулицею
коли в мене паличка з'явилася Ми ходили
Ось так само за руку ілєра допомагала
мені якщо треба було повертати кудись
вона повертала рукою вона поворачивала
рукою зараз пара разом із нами підійшла
до особливого для них місця рад суди
місяць тому вони офіційно стали
чоловіком і дружиною Я просто люблю що я
жена которая поддерживает Я просто
любляча дружина яка підтримує його в
усіх починаннях в усіх успіхах у всіх
поразках і дає мотивацію рухатися Далі
до нас на кольцах у нас на обручках
виграв Івана фраза одне ціле вона зараз
Мої очі і руки ми просто одне ціле
робимо одне і теж з однаковими помислами
цього літа Владислав та Валерія
зважилися на ще спільний крок разом
заснувати благодійний фонд допомоги
ветеранам що отримали Тяжкі поранення на
фронті побачимо перемогу його мета не
лише оплачувати лікування бійцям а й
допомагати їм з контактами фахових
спеціалістів та адаптацією до нового
життя Для цього пара вже підписала
кілька меморандумів про співпрацю з
реабілітаційними центрами в Україні Моя
багаторічна організація моя благодійна
організація буде змінювати найбільшу
несправедливість людина яка потрапляє в
біду їй треба шукати інформацію і шукати
допомогу я хочу стати організацією яка
буде шукати людину щоб дати їй
інформацію і надати допомогу щоб для
людини яка потрапила в біду я був першим
який знаєте я поруч Я вже допомагаю
зараз пара прямує до бійця який так само
як і Владислав пережив втрату зору А ще
ампутацію половину роки після поранення
на фронті у березні 2022-го владиславі
Валерія одразу вирішили допомогти йому
Бажаю здоров'я
Я знаю у тебе щось конечностю проблема Я
знаю у тебе з кінцівкою проблема так у
мене ось а ти з кимось щодо цього
консультувався ще ні
ось це одна з моїх пропозицій для тебе я
розповім тобі про моїх партнерів Я
впевнений вони зможуть допомогти
присідає Владислава
Дякую за ліворуч був в мене ліве вухо
тільки чує Я можу переговорити надіслати
твої документи і якщо ти готовий тебе
зможуть прийняти у Львівському
реабілітаційному центрі
і єслі готов тебя могут принять во
львовском реабилитационном центре
забрали
4 онлайн його коштів на лікування в
нього не лишилося але три тижні тому
його зір на одному оці врятували завдяки
допомозі фонду Владислава тою платив
операцію зі встановлення бійців нової
рогівки пройшло три недели пройшло три
тижні як мені зробили операцію пішов
четвертий тиждень я бачу результат і
дякую Богові дякую Богові що він відкрив
твоє серце Владислава твоє серце
Владислав я понимаю его я розумію його
дуже тому що сам я півтора року не бачив
це темрява така
темнота така
цифру у відео цифри побачив літери я так
зрадів
це справді дорогого вартує У мене у
самого емоції мріє Владислава зараз
допомагати таким бійцям як Олексій також
і лікуванням за кордоном А ще взяти
участь у реформуванні системи
реабілітації ветеранів у майбутньому Для
цього він певний У нього є все підтримка
коханої Віра в себе та бачення Перемоги
України у війні з Росією
Дайте мені зараз скажу Дайте мені одне
робоче око і я повернуся назад до своїх
хлопців Я готовий на 100%. але ні На
жаль цього не буде тому коли мені
сказали про те що все очей не буде я
зрозумів що треба життєві сили та
енергію віддавати на щось інше бути не
потрібними просто існувати я не буду Я
буду корисним і буду жити я не буду Я
буду полезно Я буду жить